[MUSIC]
When you complete this
program in person,
you spend most of your
time in classrooms.
Online, we use a variety of tools
to mimic the classroom experience.
We'll spend the bulk of this orientation
covering the tools that you'll
use during your time in
the Master's program.
>> We'll talk about tools you'll use for
registering for classes.
We'll talking about the learning
management system you'll use for
submitting assignments, retrieving
syllabi, and accessing class resources.
We'll talk about tools you'll use
to interact with your classmates,
professors and teaching assistants.
We'll talk about tools you'll use
to access lecture materials and
course notes.
And we'll talk about tools you'll use to
attend office hours, retrieve grades,
take exams and
manage your Georgia Tech account.
>> We know that all this information
may be overwhelming right now.
You don't need to worry about
completely understanding every tool
we talk about today.
We have just two goals.
One, to give you some initial experience
with the tools you'll be using.
And two, to make you aware of the
options and resources available to you.